I'll be going over my solution in a
second but if you want to inspect it for
yourself you can find a link to it in
the downloadable section first things
first I want my images to fit I set the
max width on the image tag to 100% and
look at that now the images are actually
fitting inside the viewport you can see
the whole thing instead of some massive
stretched out monster then I set the
width on the article tag to 50m you can
immediately see that the content is
actually fitting the blog starting to
look a lot more reasonable but the
browser is still downloading images that
are way too large and need some smaller
images I could use a tool like OS 10s
preview to resize and compress each
image individually but that really isn't
scalable so I use this grunt task to
create new images that were scaled and
compressed I set width of 1600 pixels
for two X displays at a width of 50 M on
a 1x display an image is going to be 800
pixels across but on a 2x display it's
going to be 1600 pixels so I went with a
large one I thought 30% still look good
while keeping the bytes to a minimum
additionally I'm appending large 2x to
the end of each file for reasons that
will make sense later in the course with
all that done all I have to do is change
the image sources to images / whatever -
1600 large 2x and bam my page just got a
lot smaller check it out after the
changes my page is down to 1.3 megabytes
which I'm feeling really good about and
lastly I use the figure tag because it
includes the awesome fake caption tag
simply fill in the caption in figcaption
and it shows up on the page so the blog
is looking a lot better overall but it's
still not perfect at the end of the next
lesson you'll have another chance to
improve the blog